do we have uh Alex zooming in
um
yes yes she said
she said okay
it's not three o'clock yet
foreign
I don't know
you don't have one come out here no no
that was at three o'clock yep okay let's
we go
okay welcome to the uh
council meeting for Tuesday the 29th of
November
um we have an apology from councilor
cracker who unfortunately has
uh covert so she'll attempt to zoom in
shortly any other apologies
obviously now
there's a project we received sorry
we received yes thank you got that
um
okay and welcome to John who's uh here
to do some public submission later on
when we get to the city center
governance group project update later on
so we just work our way through the
agenda uh first
half a dozen or more items are just
confirming the minutes of previous
meetings
so the first year is the minutes of the
inaugural meeting of council held on the
1st of November moved thank you second
second
in the discussion about those minutes
there being none all those in favor
carried
minister of the extraordinary meeting on
the 1st of November
moved moved again this is really easy
when you're moving second with the same
people
um
any discussion
here being none all those in favor
carried
the minutes of the infrastructure
committee meeting held on the 8th of
November I'll move that enough thank you
yeah thank you Peter
um any discussions around those minutes
yes yeah thank you
um yeah look on page three of the
minutes it um I asked the question
about
um during the meeting about the per
capita rate of uh kilos rubbish per
household now
um
I was told that there would be it says
there would be brought back to council
now I'm not sure whether that was
literally brought back to this meeting
but um I assumed it would be
um the question was reasonably
straightforward
and uh just needed obviously a couple of
weeks to grab that information so
I'm not sure
if it's going to happen or whatever it
would be my assumption that if a
committee asked for some further
information that would come back to the
next committee meeting as opposed to
coming back to full Council
okay right yeah
no that's fine yep thank you
any other issues
no uh put that's about done all those a
favor all right
carried
um can we just clarify was councilor
pottinger moving the recommendations as
well he did yeah oh sorry yeah
so the minutes of the uh extraordinary
council meeting held on the 8th of
November
Sunday
yep thanks Tom
any discussion around life
okay being none all those in favor
minutes of the committee will be in
committee
appropriate name to keep Darren Happy on
the 15th of November
thank you after facetiousness
any discussion around those minutes
they're being none of all those in favor
Municipal finance and projects committee
meeting on the 22nd of November
yep Grant thank you
very any discussion around those
there being none all those in favor
I carried
minister of the extraordinary meeting of
Council on the 22nd of November
thank you lazy
seconded thank you
any discussion around the minutes
being none all those in favor
Kerry all right on to the more meaty
topics that we've got we've got the
Amendments of Delegation register
Council and finance
and it has three recommendations as well
so the first recommendation is to
receive the report entitled amendments
to the delegation register Council and
finance
second recommendation is to revoke the
delegation for Easter Council and
finance of 2022 version one
and the third recommendation is to adopt
the delegation address to council and
finance
2022 version 2 is set out in appendix
one
I take it people have had a chance to
read that
and we have Michael here to answer any
questions
give me a clock
Standard Process mayor Clark I'm
comfortable with the recommendations
which are just a part of a process of
Shifting things about as the new Council
takes place so happy to move those three
recommendations thank you maybe the
second of those thank you Leslie
um any further discussion
there being none all those in favor
carried
so uh Russell or Aaron
absolutely
Russell is Aaron
welcome to the meeting John
so we have a series of recommender uh
three recommendations again that the
report titled City Center governance
group project update being received the
notes from that John Green the chair of
the city center governance group will
speak to this
and notes the attachment of the full
report which went to the finance and
projects committee on the 22nd of
November
the floor is yours John yeah good
afternoon thank you mayor Clark
counselors and officers
um thanks for having me back
and I guess it's the last time for the
year so you'll be the site
um just a really quick update really in
just a little bit of talk about moving
from stage one and obviously the
contentious topic of stage two so we
just want to add a bit of color to that
think of where we're thinking at the
moment so um
we can just move on to the next slide
thank you so just want to cover off
really stage one we were at um
need to have we chat about whether
there's going to be some sort of
official
um
opening of stage one
um a little bit about inner city
promotion and then we'll have WeChat
about stage two so
um obviously I'm just just any questions
please just yell out um this was a
picture the first line on the slide was
the artist impression that what we set
out to achieve
um back at the beginning of the project
and if we could just move on to the next
one
there's a aerial shot taken I think
beginning of last week kindly provided
to us by ICL
but you see that uh suddenly take shape
and I'm sure everyone is familiar with
it another shot again of that
and just again and that actually looks
like a render but it's actually a photo
and it just gives you an idea that the
concept is coming together the way that
it was proposed and what was signed off
on at the beginning of this project has
been delivered
thank you so stage one
um I think the challenges of competing
this project are to the time frames of
our catalog there is no point
re-litigating those here it was
ambitious we're coming up a little bit
short but I think that more importantly
as we've discussed before that the
quality objective has been achieved and
that after all was you know I mean
things cost money it's what do you get
what did you get what you paid for in my
view we've certainly delivered on that
um just worth mentioning as we have done
previously collaboration between the
projects has exceeded expectations
uh where we are though as we get to the
pointy end of this and as convergence is
where the projects are starting to want
to
um share the same workspace
um that might
not be the same over the next month or
so but obviously every effort has been
made to um bring these projects in and
play nicely I guess with all the parties
involved so that's really important but
um you know we're getting near the
shopping
obviously there's been conversations
around cost and I believe that it's
intended to revisit that at a future
meeting but there are project learnings
all the way through it's a good
opportunity to understand those get
those insights and use these when
planning the future work and I think um
what I would say around the costs from
what I'm privy to I mean you may have
had more information than me is that
um you know there have been obviously a
lot of things around escalation around
covert delays and all the rest
um I think it's fair to say there was
not
undue optimism in the budget so this
isn't just purely about putting up a
budget and selling it and then saying
all right we know we're going to be over
um the insights we'll be looking for is
how could the team across the board have
managed this better or was there any
opportunity to manage it better and we
should always be asking ourselves those
questions no matter whether it's a big
budget or a small budget whether on
budget or whether they're over budget so
that's something that I guess we're keen
to keep alive and as we go forward
um next slide thank you
um just on completion as I mentioned
beginning
um any official opening needs to be
planned briefed organized Before
Christmas
um so just keeping that in mind we have
no steer on exactly what anyone may be
thinking in this area
um suggestion we're looking at would be
recommending that it be the end of
February very early March otherwise we
don't need to be 100 complete to
celebrate this um
you know project but the scope of that
does need to be discussed soon
um and mindful that people are mindful
of budget and
um you know what comes next so that's
something that perhaps Council can
provide some steer back to the various
people involved
but I think it should be marked with
some form of event we just need to
discuss the scale of that
thank you
participate dating
um City Center promotion
um
coordinated approach to city center
promotion that remains challenging and I
think it'd be um optimistic to think of
it as any different uh the work that um
Kirsten Harper who was working at Great
South unfortunately has just moved on to
another role
the job she did is a link between the
contractors the project team the
businesses demonstrated that there was
both a need that level of liaison and an
excellent opportunity because really
that has um made a lot of the disruption
and the um
or inconvenience that this project has
created for a large number of people
that has gone incredibly smoothly
relative to what it could have been so
um having people on the ground and
having a face in front of people have
certainly took the pressure off Russell
and his team and um probably fair to say
that now that Kirsten and Fortune has
moved on that that is going back on to
Downer and I guess to some extent onto
Russell as well to just keep everyone
informed of what's going on
in the background we've been working
um with chief executive of council and
great South and starting to build a city
center promotional Steering group to
identify the needs established establish
a program work out what resource and
required and secure funding that's very
early days that involves participation
from ICL from ilt from both ICC and
great South and some independent
retailers and I've been asked to just
get that up and running
over the next six months
um it's envisage that delivery would be
sourced through Great South but that is
something that she had to come out of of
the dialogue but um I think we've talked
before about the need to make the most
of this investment and the best thing to
do there is to make sure we activate it
we animate it
and get as many people through this new
development as we can you're probably
may have heard we've had a fairly solid
campaign radio campaign on uh leading up
to Saturday so it ran for 10 days heavy
saturation on Radio starts again next
week if you're sick of it that starts
again
um churning Port
um and that starts on Tuesday next week
and runs for a week and a half as well
so that's been made possible with some
support from both Council and great
South so thank you for that
um but what we really want to talk about
is stage two
refocus I've called this
governance group preferences for
continuity and to maintain momentum and
I've sat here before and talked about
how important it is to build on what has
been achieved the job isn't done
we're anxious to see this renewal
process go beyond is Condon for these
two streets to be connected and for
streetscapes to be the Catalyst of
further in your one I believe that is
starting to Bubble Up and that is
exactly what we need to happen
um but having said that we're we're not
um tone deaf we've heard
the noise I guess you'd say around
funding around priorities around
concerns with inflation and CFO is sort
of started looking at reassessing those
priorities and whether there is some
element of compromises required as we've
said along our desire is not to
compromise on quality it is to have a
look a change of scope rather than lose
the momentum of what we've achieved and
also the concern about potential of
losing the IP that's been accumulated
because there is a lot of Ip that has
been built both in the council team and
The Wider project team with the
designers and with the contractors
there's a lot of value in that and we
just seem to want to see that washed
away
so um today I just wanted to put in
front of you um some thoughts if we
could move on thank you next slide so
really important we believe that we link
yes Condon streets uh don't just leave
them it's two disconnected development
uh we see that I'll bring up a plan
shortly but um yes Calvin and Don Calvin
intersections We Believe are an
important part of the connectivity we've
talked a lot in the early days of Master
Plan about
the permeability of the city that we
need to be able to continue we've got
good connection with the East we've got
good connection coming south from the
northern side of these streets we're
still struggling on the west for
connectivity and with taste Street we do
have some connectivity issues around on
coming from the south so um really Keen
to see
this the work we've done so far
supported by making it a better
connected with the immediate environment
so those two intersections we think are
critical for the flow of people
um really believe that we need to
connect
um the two streets with the upgrade of
Kelvin and just in that one block
and then some superficial Tiding of
these streets so when you come out of
langlands that you can connect back to
East Street with a similar feel that's
about branding that's about bringing
colors into line that is about some tidy
up that's about working with those
landlords to get some better quality
finish along these Street in that part
second part of that is in our view and
if you like you might say forfeiting the
initial scope of State uh steps or stage
two which was to come along yes is now
that we're getting some thinking around
distinction that the master plan refresh
has started to look at what the place
has been important to connect that
saying let's move that money let's move
that investment into connecting the
distinction hotel with the city
addressing the wattner place issue which
is I think a long-standing issue for the
city I think you have to imagine if you
will a a visitor coming out of the
distinction Hotel onto the footpath and
saying where am I going for breakfast
where am I going to go shopping today
after breakfast how connected to the
city are they as opposed to Connected
just to cars and buses and going in the
opposite direction so that's really
important to us and the refresh of the
master plan is looking at those areas
and saying right as at times start
thinking just weave it outside that
original City Center a couple of blocks
so um
that's what's driving that thinking
there are some other thoughts around
that in terms of why you know we think
that's probably a an hour a bigger
priority than coming along esk
um you know and I think that the
distinction again needs the support that
we've given langdon's and we've given
the other developments so what we've got
up here on the board the two blue zones
of course what we're finishing now
the two intersections are um highlighted
with those red circles a little bit of
green that extends Beyond those
intersections is really just the
Feathering in of those upgrades it's not
about bringing everything along the
street
um so the extra actual scope of those
would still need to be determined
um the dotted purple lines
um we're affectionately referred to this
as the lipstick
but you know there's a bit more than
that but the idea is to dress it up as
an interim holding position for those
two precincts and the key really the
challenge in this is working out a
strategy for what in the place now
there's some work being done on that by
the master plan refresher committee uh
it's not due to be tabled I think till
March or so
but um this is the thinking we've had
I've socialized this with Council
officers I've socialized with the mayor
last week and our governance group
meeting we had last week was in support
of us refocusing on to
um this what you might call inclusivity
around bringing distinction of what in
place into the model so that's what it
looks like on on a plan and if we just
go to the last slide thank you so our
recommendation is if your support would
be to ask the project team which is a
mixture of the officers and the
designers to investigate the costs
designs obviously in the potential
timelines associated with the reduced
scope for stage two so this is about the
product prioritization of these spaces
I've outlined we need to know what those
costs are we need to understand exactly
what's under the ground for Russell and
his team in terms of three Waters and
anything else that needs to go on how
that interface faces with those programs
what that means for the other Capital
programs are going so what the timelines
would look like and what resources
required and I would envisage that would
be probably
March at best if we come back with that
challenging thought we got Christmas
we've got all the rest of things to go
with that may take a bit longer but
rather than let's just say kickstage two
for touch for now or put it on hold or
defer it I think we should keep planning
we should keep working and we should be
looking at you know modifying recutting
our cloth and coming back with something
solid that you can get your teeth into
foreign
but I'd like to know where you think the
where to from here for the group itself
um well I think that the feedback we've
had because that's a question that I've
only been asking as well was what
happens to governance group
um at the end of stage one and I think
that we would probably take the view
that if there are if there is work to do
the governor's group carries on if
there's no work to do well thanks for
having us and
um you know we'll see you on the other
side
um but I think
um
the feedback I get is the
um the people who we have worked with
and have touched them on my mother have
valued the existence of the governance
group obviously as a council have you
valued it that's your you know you'll
have your own opinion but um
could we have done more to link with the
community possibly but it is voluntary
and it is people giving up their time
but I think we've been able to join the
dots for the project
to support the council officers to
engage in multiple levels with vismas
and we've had the access to one of their
principals which has been on our
committee and that's been invaluable
we've learned a lot and I guess I would
say
we've invests all the time in this
there's a lot of knowledge being
acquired be useful to put it to work
somewhere in this project yep so some
further comment for me John
um when you refer to the lipsticker
you're just referring to the facades of
the buildings is that when you're
primarily okay I think Italian D sorry
good question
um my focus on branding and
um
if you know you shouldn't need signs to
tell you that you're in the city center
you should feel like you're in the city
center so for me if you've been in a
very you know finished environment like
langlands and you go going down to
history to go to the mall go the
retailers go to Ace or you are tell
whatever I think there should be a level
of continuity in that experience sure
um so that's about making sure our
footpath is level and got no potholes in
it that's about talking to those
property owners and encouraging them
um firmly strongly to um clean and up
their premises to maybe check on
lighting and underground lighting and
make sure that's operating to a standard
and obviously encouraging facades I
think you've got to be careful about how
easy it is to spend a lot of money and I
think you would want to stop at the very
level what happens above there sure it's
a big makes a big impression from the
other side of the road
uh to have to prioritize but I think
it's it's
um it's trying to again get those
private property owners to come to the
party
two and for those that obviously went
party to our discussion last week um
clearly there are some roadblocks for us
in in the continuity you refer to one is
that we Face some fairly horrible
potential increases to rates so we have
to look right across the board at what
we're doing and it's not the only
project we're looking at
stage two being not the only project
we're looking at
um and secondly um I mean I like what
you've done on the redraft there
um that probably hits all the buttons
that I was campaigning on before the
election but again it's affordability
for us
um I don't want any work that you do to
sit on the shelf and collect dust that
would be the worst outcome for you
um but the issue of getting staff to do
some work before about March to um cost
out so many things I think
my colleague to the left of me will
probably to your right will probably say
that the work we need to do around the
rates and how we claw back the potential
impacts for next year is going to gobble
up all her start time
um so I guess it's it's hard for us to
commit that time frame I think oh no I
don't think we would expect to come in I
think we've got to find a starting point
yeah so guess what I'm suggesting but
um
and reality knows my job to push
um for what we'd like to see happen sure
um I think we've proven we're reasonable
people
um and I guess you know you you might
say well if it takes a bit longer do
that and want to do it properly we don't
want
um estimates only we don't want optimism
we want reality and then we need to know
what we're doing
um but you know I think that time will
pass fairly quickly we'd rather
consider the idea of of
um rationalizing stage two and and then
combining it with incorporating what we
need to do for distinction development
and ideally mark off the what the place
challenge at the same time so that
refocus will say we'll take some time
but I'll potentially
um you know we're shifting some money
from what would have been in the year
Street part of that project sure and
from my Pacifica but I mean it's not a
matter of do we do what you suggested I
think that from my perspective that's a
really good way to go avoid this end of
s Street and reinvest towards walk the
place uh the issue for us is when can we
afford it I appreciate that yep thank
you Tom
foreign
stage two there's there's obviously at
least three maybe four stages within
that stage because you can walk the
place you've got the you know you get
Kelvin Street you've got the proposal to
the lipstick proposal for for D and for
T and it seems to me be useful when you
come back to
you know look at it rather than a single
project but maybe put the sensible
staging of that might be you know which
which is the most important you know
what should we do first but you know so
that as we so that as we're thinking
about you know how that aligns with
budget going forward we can think in
terms of just one stage but maybe three
or four stages yeah yeah thank you and I
think that below ground work
and how that interfaces with other
projects will inform that as well so I
think it's it's really just saying let's
just think of it conceptually for now we
just go away and do some work and then
bring it back as a of your life comes
reassess priorities as to how we can
find some compromise to go forward and I
agree that it's it's a it's a series of
jobs and again these guys will
um will sit me in the right direction
foreign
do we have any idea around the time
frame for the distinction Hotel
no I don't
um other people here may
um but
um
I expect jobs when I take a bit longer
than yeah what's planned yeah so um that
would also I guess if we did have some
we would be able that would inform
um what the deputy mayor suggested
the presentation we had from Jeff
Thompson previous said about September
next year
I think it will be optimistic yes
yes I think
I guess if I could ask Mr Mia sure was
anyone because I know some of you are
very strong
um supporters of us pushing on the stage
two end of the projects
um I wonder if anyone was concerned
about the suggestion of refocusing and
reassessing the scope of stage two
um I can help you with one uh certainly
Council of Crockett said to me she was
opposed to delaying stage two in its
original form right so I'm assuming
she's not zooming in today but I'm
assuming she'll still be opposed Mr
Mayor I have concerns as well sure
um my concerns
um
of losing that momentum and the amount
of effort that it takes to get things
started up again let alone the potential
loss of IP
um I look at what was suggested with the
lipstick proposal as a potential
um
adequate stop Gap measure
I will note that I sit in the lipstick
Zone in my day job
um
but
um but we don't have the information and
and so that's what I'm Keen to see
fleshed out and come back to council
cool thank you then then I'm in a better
position to be able to make a comparison
at the moment I still really support
stage two yep
I'm interested in seeing the further
information and I agree it is sensible
to proceed on what has been suggested
here
um and with that information we will try
much better picture of of how we're
going to make our decisions
there you go uh yes Mr Mayor um
I too support the original stage two but
I'm curious about the
um
vision for the circle areas given that
those
um
that Dawn Street East Street boasts come
to a point that the buildings on all
those Corners are in good repair and
condition what was the vision that would
happen within the circles and that's not
well identified in what you've shown to
us that would make me happy about giving
up
um the vision that stage two was
likewise I do think it's important that
we look at s Street West
I don't like the term lipstick and
[Music]
um
I'll think about an alternative uh
however I do
think that some of those businesses that
are on those peripheral areas have have
they been engaged in these discussions
I've been I'm sorry they've been engaged
in the master planning and at the
beginning here
um when we started talking about staged
approach and priorities
you know they're probably some of those
areas would have been five years down
the track and we're saying right now
just to get a level of
um
sort of a
cohesive sort of feel is that it's
probably worthwhile doing some interim
work it shouldn't be seen as being
kicking it for touch it should just be
seen as let's just get some
um a little bit of continuity across
this area and just just bring them up to
standard for now while we work through
what is clearly going to be some
medium-term funding challenges
well you guys are more over the funding
challenges than I am but
um you know I think we've we've
recognized that we need to prioritize
so I think in in general to you Mr Beer
for
Clarity of of my thoughts
we need more information on the
um proposed amendments to the stage two
project to be able to say well it's
worth the trade-off
um
at the moment what we'd just be doing is
speculating
totally um we've there's no intention to
get any decisions I think the idea here
is to Pivot a little
and um say what is achievable
is really where we're coming from
thank you
Nigel thank you
um I was a huge supporter of stage two
in stelland although I applaud the
refresh that you're doing and looking at
and obviously more information we can
get going forward there's always
Solutions obviously a lot of great fan
of lipstick actually I prefer the
natural look John so
please be careful with that to be honest
right but it just covers up a multitude
of sins doesn't it but um
all the feedback around what you've done
what the team has done around stage one
has been significant it's been fabulous
to a person so to our community here but
to the visitors that come it's been
staggering so congratulations on that I
think we just pause we get as much
information as we can going forward and
we'd love to finish in some shape or
form what we can you know we're going to
the ball we've all got our new gear that
the band's not playing yet so I think we
should uh see if what we can do and
achieve in that time thank you well
uh yeah I also uh have always supported
stage two I think what's happening in
the central city is just absolutely
marvelous but I also
um am I aware of the the restraints that
we're going to have financially over the
next year or two and I think uh the way
that Tom's proposing that perhaps we
look at staging the stage two if you
like might be a Way Forward
and tied in perhaps with the distinction
S1 and so forth lipstick idea is okay
for me I'm a problem with that I think I
think you do need to include Tay and D
something needs to be done there
so um and full credit to what what's
what's happened already
um I just like to say that um yeah
but I'm also a fan of living within
their means and so so to me I'm really
interested in in the detail of the
changes around that but also I
I think we need to celebrate in some way
from stage one because I was out there
on the week on the weekend and thought
that was fantastic you know the the
people out
you know it was just huge very well done
team yeah
Ellen I think it's absolutely amazing
that your photo looks exactly like a
drawing that's incredible because that
very really ever happens normally yeah
and again I just needed we need to make
sure that credit goes where it's true
which is the project team which is
Russell and his group there is Miss
Consultants
um I think they've done a really good
job
Korea and through you Mr Mia I just
wanted to say um John that um together
with the project team the governance
team Council and everyone collaborated
together we should be really proud that
we've made it into generational change
for our city and the transformation and
the ability of what our future can look
like is pretty amazing
um and I hear what you're saying like
you've had some learnings from stage one
that you'll look at applying into a
reviewed stage two I also think I'm
concerned that we will lose momentum
that our people here are really proud of
what we've achieved I with cost barriers
in mind of the future which we've got
facing us I think that um it would be
really good to know the facts it's hard
to make decisions on Concepts all the
time and I'm all for saving money in our
community when we're faced with some
challenges in the future so thank you
thank you
you're ringing
um
just a comment from being on the
committee with John and I applaud him
starting at 7 15 in the morning it uses
up as otherwise I wasted
um look listening to the designers at
the start when we did the walk around
invercargill with this Miss and then
listening to David Niven who's the
advisor from from SMS on our committee
uh the feeling I get is there is far
greater need to focus on the what in the
place linking D Street with the other
side of D Street than there is in in
kelvin and if you're going to spend any
money when it comes to that decision is
that is where they they as professionals
see that invercargill needs it
um right right from day one even though
we were telling them no no no forget
about walk the place it's not in the
it's not the scope it's Dan Don they
were really interested in in solving you
know that issue that we've got there so
my my view is that you know if we're
gonna if we're gonna go ahead with stage
two
then it should be we should really sort
out that issue rather than just go
blindly onto Kelvin Street where I'm
just looking back I was just reading uh
the minutes from 2013 where we approved
11 million dollars in um in remedial
work to the very spot we're going to do
up you know
um so I yeah that's that's my view on on
life as it is Barry yeah um I'm I
congratulate you for all the work you've
done on stage one it looks really good
but
um on stage two I agree with rainy with
the walking in place we need to
concentrate on that rather than the
Kelvin street because all those
retailers have suffered big time
with all the work that's been done
between those two intersections so yeah
thank you for those comments I'll get
Russell to speak on what other work
needs to be done in kelvin in a second
but um
I think the retailers have come through
it better
than they ever expected
and I think that the dichotomy is going
to be if when you pull a pin if you pull
the pin on what was planned for stage
two is those retailers who have been
aware of what's gone on they're going to
suddenly turn around and go oh well so
you spent all the money on those guys
what happens to us
um
and you know and that's that's the other
side of the coin but I think that the
retailers have traded better
than they either
feared whoever hoped
um and in fact some and I guess we've
been a wee bit lucky that the Sugar Rush
that followed the 2020 lockdowns has
been extremely kind to some of those
people
so that is more is compensated for that
some of those impacts so um this is why
it's important we get out there and
support them but I think um
the
the data available from Chad credit card
spending and things in the precinct
there's shown not the adverse impacts
everyone expected
okay and again that's
that's only anecdotal because getting
retailers to tell you their numbers
pretty difficult thank you
clearly
I'm treating it on what in a place at
the expense of Calvin
um
I one of my big concerns and why I would
like the more information if we're going
to make any amendments is that I have
always seen this as a very much joined
up
process so we always intended to create
the city sound center that included the
boundaries of Calvin Street
and
the Italian D and so forth
um I would be really concerned
if we
um talked about what kind of place is
replacing Kelvin because I would be
really concerned that we left
the great vision we had as to
unconnected
um projects and I see Calvin street is
actually an essential part of connection
so I just wanted to make that point and
yes I agree we should definitely look at
what we're going to place and I've
always said what in a place has to be a
part of it but I would be very
very reluctant to see what can a place
take over from the connectedness of of
the original Vision thank you so John
for your benefit just a bit of a pricey
there
um I'm not sure that um
rang who's been on your group actually
said that we would cancel
um Kelvin Street I think what he was
saying was that the priority might be to
go to Wagner first and you mentioned uh
in your presentation here he was a
staged approach to stage two and and
framesake if the lipstick was first and
walking was second then Kelvin was third
it might come into some degree of
affordability for us but do you see it
because I'm picking the lipstick as you
refer to it
I'm like we'll keep repeating it for
dinner as a benefit so it gets
normalized to it
um the lipstick is um may not may not be
a costly excite I'm regretting the use
of that term yeah no no it's all good
right now I I think
um
I guess when we we scoped stage two in a
winter consultation and it was a
gradient principle that's where we hit
it and then the distinction there's a
potential development came on them on
the horizon okay that would have been
possibly stage three what we've said is
let's concatenate those two into one
right sized sure
um and prioritize and go which bits can
continue to sell their own canoe which
ones need to
um do we need to get some help and when
we're on balance we think that we need
to support any major Capital project
like that as we have done for the others
but I I'm like you
um cancer sober I think that Calvin is
is critical to the walk through walk
around connectivity but um can I just
ask Russell to just comment on what
other work may need to be done in kelvin
Street I know you come to the stage
because I'm going to ask in on the card
questions so um
so um one is the issue of the retailers
in kelvin Street I did a walk through
with them about two weeks ago I didn't
get to all them but I got the most and
most of them are not keen to have
[Music]
um
the history upgrade running through
Kelvin at this stage it didn't say no to
her but they do they were just nervous
they said they were very much like the
duster settle in the mall and for some
of the shop that potentially might be
vacant around the mall
before we actually had to cover which I
thought was interesting
um but the other thing is I'll just ask
you taking your
leadership role off off this group and
um
giving you a rate pass view on this
um we've had debate before about whether
we as Council should invest in lipstick
for one of a better Words which is
upgrading some of those facades where
there are owners that cannot afford it
or they don't have the rental increase
in the outer has always been no so I
just wonder what your view of that is
when you talk about lipstick which is I
guess potentially water blasting and
repainting some of those facades if we
if we had roadblocks from
um some business owners who we can't
force we can only encourage and we've
explored the option of potential bylaws
and that's not an option either
um would it be something you you believe
as a right pie should be worth investing
in from a council perspective to get
that overall feel of those arterial
streets as well or should we leave that
aside I think if there's a vacant
property and the land orders
um not willing to do anything and
ideally we would still find a way to
clean it sure and bring up scratch and
if necessary put vinyls on the Windows
sure I think when it comes to how a
willing owner then maybe the con
consideration being given to
technical advice on what their options
are I don't personally believe that
Council should be spending money
other than what I call housekeeping on
private owners property and I see it a
little bit like what will need to happen
around New Zealand with um public
private partnership around seismic
because it's one thing to provide some
engineering advice or to provide some
um help provide some solutions it's a
different thing to go and spend public
money on someone's private property so I
I see it as being how do you facilitate
it not doing the work for them
as a rate payer personally
and we wouldn't expect you to do that
foreign
but I guess uh one feedback I've got
from some other cities I've been asking
around is that some some buildings are
vacant or alternative there
are three stories high which most of
ours are and there's nothing on the top
two stories and and some very
lightweight retail on the bottom
um and some some councils I've looked to
and cars they've got into Partnerships
where they pay a little and the owner
pays a little bit or they're provided
the cherry picker for one or better
words than the water blaster but the
painting work gets done by the owner or
whatever I think you'd want a pretty
solid
written agreement with them and they
were going to do their bit sure
I think one of the things to keep in
mind in new zealanders we have this
requirement to have varendas
you know because of our climate and
usually it's a bylaw in my city so you
have to have Brandis well for when you
can make comparisons to what you see in
other countries and other cities is they
don't have that requirement so that you
get quite a contrast in how the building
faces the street and how it's maintained
so it's one of the downsides of having
to have these Rangers
um as a compulsory item is that there's
not a lot of Maintenance goes on above
them I know that Dunedin at one stage to
try to pass a bylaw or I understand to
the four thousand George Street to come
up to scratch and that fell through
yep I think it ringy
thanks chair
um look they're walking in place
upgrade it's not solid waffle place you
know it's it's not fair to think of it
as that the designers are very keen and
they've stressed how there is a massive
disconnect between the west side of D
Street
and what we perceive as our city center
now you look at the quest Hotel you've
got the tuatare you've got all the
business Spates over there everything
over there thriving part of town but
they see it and these are the experts
these are not councilors sitting back
um being streetscape Engineers
um
so they see it
is a very important thing to connect
I see
in fact I do it quite a bit I will
between isk and Don down Kelvin street
it's not difficult I I seem to be able
to get there without too many injuries
um so you know I guess
listening to experts is is quite good
and beneficial you know if they see a
major fault and and and you ignore it
and and follow on with Blind Faith
um
and and what you've well we've consulted
on it and so on and so on and so on uh
sorry that's not my way of doing
business
thank you Russell oh sorry Tom if you're
quick I was gonna come in on the
um the shop Frontage question and and I
think we we have to think there about
who are the beneficiaries and the
reality is that a few of tobacconists
that's unlikely she is tobacconist on
the ground floor you don't gain much
actually by putting a lot of money into
cleaning up the frontage on the second
floor and the third floor
uh the the beneficiary is wider than the
beneficiary as a city actually right
rather than only that individual shops
or I I think we do have to be open to
that proposition uh I will comment on
what kind of place I I think compared to
when stage two was first looked at
however longer that was you know I think
there's new information since then and
that is a question in your hotel
and that is going to change the center
of gravity I think towards the South so
South it is
um and you know and I think we have to
take that account as we think about our
you know potentially revised uh stage
two something
through you Mia
John and Russell just to help me with
the distinction delivery on the day uh
with with Chief and his team there was
some discussion around
um walking a place obviously and their
commitment to the uh will say the uplift
or the facelift of the area itself can
you recall the detail around it there
was we did have some discussion and Jeff
made some comment I believe
oh you know sorry John I thought you
were but uh Russell were you excluded uh
Russell you might be able to help but I
just understand from the delivery there
seemed to be some genuineness from from
Jeff Around The Wider development or
have I got that wrong
thanks Mr me and councilors
um
the thing the distinction hotels
um I guess
design has actually been growing and
we've had a number of conversations
but if you could perhaps give me a
little bit of indulgence I think some of
these things will pull together quite
quite nicely is that
um we have been doing some work on um
what we would describe as the master
plan refresh which looks specifically at
that piece of West of D Street and
because for the first stage of the city
center we really focused on the east
side so I think that's a key element
that we need to bring back what that
actually means will be how the
distinction Hotel actually operates and
how we connect we have what in place
cutting off East Street West at the
moment so
um it's a matter of I think how their
design how their accessed for their
buses all those things start to actually
work together and and the range of
options that you could actually
contemplate for that whole area and how
you're linked to D Street
how we fund and what the extent of is
Street West is I think that's actually
a step further down the path of actually
understanding what we actually want it
to actually deliver
but I think
one of the things that I would encourage
people to think a little bit about is is
time one of the things that we've done
with stage one is we've been on a I've
described it as a bullet train for the
last little while it's been a it's been
a pretty busy time
um and how we use that time between now
and when we need this to use as wisely
as we can and that's not saying we need
to build anything we just need to use
our time really really really wisely
um we actually do need to build this
city with heart and everything we're
talking about is how do we fit these
people in around and I think one of the
key things that when do we want the
people in the right places so if this
distinction hotel is ahead of something
else it could well be that it's finished
and we need to be ready early so
understanding some of those timing
pieces is really part of the key
ingredient of actually but making sure
we know what we're actually have learned
in the first stage
we've learned quite a bit over the last
couple years about how this happens how
this comes together what sort of costs
are involved and where the risks are and
I think pulling that together is sort of
that last part of it
John mentioned very briefly that the
underground services that we haven't
actually thought about and unfortunately
the other things that we actually have
to put down first before we can build
anything on top so we don't come back
and Calvin Street needs some of those so
we are going to have to go to Calvin
Street and once again it's when do we do
that that we don't create disruption or
we have to leave it for too long before
we finish it is actually part of this
time issue again so I think that's
really part of the um bigger timepiece
and unfortunately I might have started
this story starting with l but I want to
change the description to renewals
because a lot of what we've talked about
perhaps in D Street and taste written
those sorts of things are things like
footpath renewals which are planned
renewals we just need to put the timing
right for them so so it's actually
addressing some of the features that are
existing we're not going to change the
shape we've just got to change the the
top surface appearance so that that
could be a different option of how we
actually address some of those issues
going forward so
I'm not sure
um yeah that I've answered your question
but I've sort of but have a mix to pull
that together because I think that's
what I've been hearing but um I guess
the biggest lesson that I've learned
over these last two years is let's
actually understand what our time
commitments and when when we need these
things so we don't actually get
ourselves into a real Rush at the end
because that's when your uncertainty
starts to come into your process and if
we're looking for a certainty for what
we're going to deliver in cost then we
need to start thinking early to be ready
for when when they're needed
so just picking up on that point
um
muscle just for John in the sense of
that opportunity now exists with
distinction in the discussion with
distinction because there's a financial
opportunity as well and Jeff's very
committed so finishing up from what
you've just said
um you know there's a bullet train
there's another train there's an Express
train going as well at the moment as
well so we're gonna have two trains on
on two fast tracks which is very
exciting but
um I just believe how long they don't
Collide Tom yeah but I just do believe
that discussion going on now with
distinction is really quite important to
us and so we get that full picture when
you come back to us and and you know who
knows there may be another opportunity
to be able to kill two birds with one
stone so just as an attempt to wrap this
up
foreign there are other factors to come
into the landscape as well so we've done
a
presentation an information Gather in
the ICL recently to Target young people
and they have some views on what the
place as well which might be quite
interesting and it might time what
you're saying Russell so we we have
other voices coming into the picture as
well yeah we would involve the designers
in that conversation yeah
so uh thank you very much for your time
thanks for giving us so much time and
getting the feedback kids appreciate it
yep thank you so we've got um we've got
uh three recommendations somebody like
to move those
Nigel
Trish thank you any further discussion
on those three recommendations
all those in favor
now uh clear advising me that we've got
a very very late item that we need to
confirm the appointments we've discussed
before to the district licensing
committee
uh going forward Mr chair the the reason
for dealing with the DLC separately to
the other appointments is that until the
DLC is established an ex-counselor
continues to be involved in doing this
work so if you could move the motion
first off that you received the major
late item that can be helpful yep thank
you and seconded you think you're
listening
so the issue is the appointment of
Darren is Cheer
Peter Ria and Leslie being on the group
somebody like to move that
Grant and Barry thank you any discussion
about that
you're being none all those in favor I I
carried
so we now need to move into public
exclusive
anomaly and signal for that yes
Darren thank you very thinking the
reason says outline we're just receiving
and confirming minutes yeah thank you
very much
see you Logan